[Music]  here's the problem okay it's Easter  right but with the economy in rough [ __ ]  many people have to stick to a tight  budget when buying Easter candy and  gifts so once again here with some more  money-saving Easter tips is our prop  master bill tall bill take two pregnancy  tests stick them in your mouth  boom bunny teeth  [Music]  [Applause]  here with another tip bill once again  buy a package of eggs take a hit of acid  moon colored eggs  Bradley bill has another one  take a TV turn on Conan boom Easter ham  well bill most of those were great but  this weekend's also the Jewish holiday  of Passover so any Passover tips go to a  priest convert to Christianity boom  Easter  [Applause]  that doesn't seem right doesn't seem  right at all  boom Easter